Lula you've already made yourself at
home at Camp ET oh hello I'm so happy to
be at this camp when do we have snacks
uh we have some candy right here Oh
delicious answer available thank you
right make it rain make it rain you know
what I mean are you enjoying seeing all
your fans your viewers i have met two
fans my dad is here I so sheltered papa
and then also in the mirror is a man
that is always liking me and I said
hello to him as where is he a very
handsome man no 2016 yes a great year
we're in it right now we're in the
middle of it what's coming up for you in
2016 hopefully uh some more months will
happen I think October's coming very
soon and then November will happen and
then I will eat some stuffing they shove
it in the turkey yes and then you eat it
out of the toilet I this feels very
inappropriate are we going to see you in
bed for victory I need to know I'm
finding out the shoots locations then I
shall sneak into the craft service table
and then I shall beat box at every scene
now I know you'll also be spinning a
little bit in the movie called dirty 30
yeah it's very dirty it's very 30 what
can you tell us about who you are in
that movie in the film I'm a man who
will be spinning some records and I am
very happy to be having a part I
explored a dairy farm some weeks ago how
about that was a fun time why were you
exploring a dairy farm Flula because I
don't I've never seen where yogurt comes
from and so I wanted to meet them but
the Mamas of yogurt okay I think we have
had enough time at campeche thank you so
much I left your camp you are like the
Michael Crichton of interviewers I don't
know what that means but ok Jurassic
Park coming soon right it's coming soon
coming soon yeah